we live in a world where Innovation is
highly prized yet replication often
holds the secret to success the
similarities between Mark Zuckerberg's
new app threads and Twitter are so
striking that Zuck acknowledged it in a
tweet Elon Musk who bought Twitter for
44 billion is now threatening to sue
meta over threads his lawyer accused it
of using Twitter's trade secrets from
ex-employees which meta denies tech
companies borrowing ideas from each
other goes back decades in the 90s
netscape's Navigator was a go-to browser
enjoying an 80 market share Microsoft
noticed and introduced Internet Explorer
which appeared to mimic Navigator's
features Microsoft offered it for free
within the Windows operating system
whereas Netscape initially charged users
by the early 2000s Internet Explorer
dominated the browser market today in
the social media Arena imitation is
everywhere YouTube launched The Tick
Tock copycat shorts Snapchat mirrored
Tick Tock with Spotlight to Twitter
spaces Drew inspiration from the audio
chat room app Clubhouse Zuckerberg has a
long history of copying a good idea when
he sees one this is our company's DNA he
cloned Tick-Tock in the form of
Instagram reels Snapchat stories were
suddenly Instagram stories he introduced
Slack's Emoji reactions and mentions
into Facebook if we go back even further
former Harvard classmates of
Zuckerberg's the Winklevoss twins sued
Zuckerberg claiming he stole the idea
for Facebook from them the case inspired
the movie The Social Network we came up
with an idea for a website called
Harvard connection and we've since
changed the name to connect to you and
Mark Zuckerberg stole that idea I
understand kind of asking what you want
me to do about it the brothers accepted
a settlement in the form of cash and
Facebook stock NOW meta stock currently
worth hundreds of millions of dollars
copying is effective because if an idea
has been successful for one company
there's a good chance it will succeed
elsewhere and we are calling it
it's iPhone
an example is how smartphone
manufacturers adopted Apple's iPhone
design after its success copying
minimizes Risk by leveraging the
research and testing already undertaken
by the innovators products are features
that are already familiar also require a
less mental effort to use or understand
when Amazon introduced one-click
ordering in 1997 it revolutionized the
online shopping experience this allowed
Shoppers to purchase anything with a
single click using a pre-setup payment
method Apple recognized the value of
this user-friendly feature in licensed
Amazon's one-click patent
and by copying an existing idea or
product there's a chance to improve it
when Instagram stories added pause
rewind and fast forward features to its
Snapchat clone it ended up surpassing
Snapchat's user base
so although imitation isn't new the
scrutiny surrounding meta's threads
could be attributed to zuck's Public
Image a third of Americans already have
an unfavorable view of him according to
a 2022 poll by the company morning
consult public perception has been
affected by controversies stemming from
Facebook's Revenue model which involves
selling information collected about its
users to allow advertisers to Target
them
when I analyze the Privacy labels from
Apple's app store it's evident that
threads collects more information than
Twitter including data characterized as
sensitive info according to Apple that
includes racial or ethnic data sexual
orientation religious and philosophical
beliefs political opinion or biometric
data which includes fingerprints and
facial recognition data a 19 year old
Zuckerberg once called people who handed
over their data dumb shortly after
he launched Facebook from his Harvard
dorm room here's the instant message
exchange between Zuckerberg and a friend
from 2004 leaked to the tech site
silicon alley Insider yeah so if you
ever need info about anyone at Harvard
just ask I have over 4 000 emails
pictures addresses social networking
sites what how'd you manage that one
people just submitted it I don't know
why they trust me dumb
when asked about these messages
Zuckerberg said he absolutely regretted
them telling the New Yorker I think I've
grown and learned a lot but now millions
of users are willingly handing over vast
amounts of personal information to
Zuckerberg 30 million people signed up
for threads on the first day making it
the most rapidly downloaded social media
app in history outstripping chat gbt
part of the draw may be that people can
easily Sun up through their pre-existing
Instagram account with a click of a
button the zekcall threads the beginning
of something special
their speculation threads is part of his
wider plan to build the metaverse
because it promises to work with
decentralized platforms which is in line
with meta's vision for the metaverse a
seamless online ecosystem where
interactions are not limited to one
specific platform like Facebook however
not all of Zuckerberg's apps have
succeeded remember when Facebook
launched lasso me neither Facebook's
answer to Tick-Tock failed miserably a
year and a half after launch Facebook's
Pinterest competitor hobby also shut
down and plenty of Twitter copycats have
struggled to maintain their traction
when Zuckerberg said that the threads
team is focusing on kindness in making
this a friendly Place some worried this
was code for censorship the main
motivation for Elon Musk to buy Twitter
was because the Tesla and SpaceX CEO
felt freedom of speech was being stifled
under previous leadership what makes it
all the more interesting is that this
Tech Duo might spill out into the real
world
musk and Zuckerberg May square off in a
UFC fight Zuckerberg is a Brazilian Jiu
Jitsu Enthusiast
musk recently spent time training with
UFC Legend George Saint Pierre who
posted a photo on Twitter of their
session speaking of Twitter why not give
news think a follow I'm now posting my
full videos on Twitter and you'll have a
ringside seat to all the actions
speaking of ringside the Italian
government has reportedly given the
green light for the fight to take place
in Rome's Coliseum
as Mark Twain once said truth is
Stranger Than Fiction
without the work of brilliant Engineers
none of these social media platforms
would be possible that level of
technical skill is something we should
all strive to cultivate and there's no
better place to start than with my
sponsor brilliant brilliant helps you
improve your math data science and
computer science skills in an
interactive way I take a few minutes out
of my day to brush up on my analytical
thinking skills by going through their
logic puzzles in the new how technology
Works course you can explore topics like
how recommendation algorithms know what
content you'll like there are thousands
of lessons from the basics to Advanced
topics you can try brilliant for free
for 30 days by signing up with my custom
link in the description
brilliant.org newsthink in the first 200
people who sign up using my custom link
will get 20 off their premium annual
subscription which gives you access to
their entire offering thanks for
watching I'm Cindy Palm